Remember, we were told that if Hillary Clinton
gets elected, she's going to start all sorts
of things.
Wars and Donald Trump won't. And this is one
of the reasons you want to elect outsider
Donald Trump instead of bloodthirsty whatever
Hillary Clinton and a fair criticisms of Hillary
Clinton's foreign policy aside. Uh, it has
actually been Donald Trump that has been pushing
the United States to the brink of war, uh,
with a number of countries seemingly more
than willing for political reasons, or even
just due to his own strange misunderstandings
of what's going on in the world. It's been
Donald Trump that increasingly is the risk.
And it now appears that Donald Trump has every
intention of taking the United States to war
with Iran. He's alluded to it. He's fainted
in that direction at different times. And
Donald Trump has now executed an assassination,
an authorized assassination of an Iranian
leader, which has every indication of being
the first major step towards a actual war
with Iran. Donald Trump hinted at this on
Twitter recently.
We looked at it yesterday in response to the
protests at the U S embassy in Iraq. Donald
Trump blaming Iran saying quote, Iran will
be held fully responsible for lives, lost
or damage incurred at any of our facilities.
They will pay a very big price. This is not
a capital w warning. It is a capital T threat.
Happy new year. Now his clueless followers
loved it. Despite these protests, clearly
not being an Iranian attack on the United
States and we've now learned that the Pentagon
at the direction of Donald Trump has assassinated
Kaseem Sola Mani, the head of Iran's codes
force. Now let's be very, very clear. This
is the equivalent of a foreign country assassinating
someone like our chairman of the joint chiefs
here in the United States military command
structure. It's really easy to get confused.
We're here in the United States, we hear an
ISIS leader has been killed or we hear the
head of the Uranian codes force has been killed
and we might sort of feel like these are equivalent
things like these are the same thing.
They are not. And to be very clear, this is
not a defense or a criticism of any particular
killing on the merits. This is simply not
the same. Once again, this is like a foreign
country assassinating the chairman of the
joint chiefs. This was not authorized by Congress,
Donald Trump, you might remember many, many
times making the, before he was president,
when it was Barack Obama, that was president,
that the president needs authorization. For
example, when Donald Trump tweeted, the president
must get congressional approval before attacking
Syria. Big mistake if he does not. So there
are two stories here. There's the legality
and authorization for this assassination.
And then there's also the political side.
The foreign policy side. Sola Mani was in
a way the second most powerful person in Iran
behind the Ayatollah. There is no doubt that
Solemani was not a friend to the United States,
much like Kim Jong moon is not a friend to
the United States.
Much like Vladimir Putin, by the way, is not
a friend to the United States, so on and so
forth. But what appears to have happened is
that the United States assassinated without
congressional authorization that Donald Trump
used to say president's needed has assassinated
the second most powerful person in another
country. And voila. The idea of Trump creating
a military conflict to muddy up the 2020 campaign
to justify his reelection in in a way, uh,
is taking place. And it was written on the
wall. The projection has been going on for
years. Remember these tweets, Donald Trump,
for example, in November of 2011 tweeting,
in order to get elected, Barack Obama will
start a war with Iran. Remember in October
of 2012 a month before the 2012 election,
Donald Trump tweeting now that Obama's poll
numbers are in tailspin watch for him to launch
a strike in Libya or Iran. He's desperate.
Remember Donald Trump tweeting quote, remember
what I previously said?
Obama will someday attack Iran in order to
show how tough he is. It's been a decade of
projection. This will escalate violence. And
aside from the legality of all of this, uh,
completely unauthorized, apparently illegal
from a practical, strategic, political perspective.
I hope people know that a war with Iran would
be nothing like the war with Iraq, which by
the way, was no walk in the park, but it was
predicted to be by people like Dick Cheney.
Iran's military is serious and formidable.
The terrain is rugged. Iran, his ability to
interfere in foreign countries is much larger
than Iraq's was in terms of its geopolitical
standing. Donald Trump may be starting the
worst, biggest, most disastrous war of my
lifetime. And that says a lot because even
just in the last 10, 15 years, we've had a
rock. We've had Afghanistan, and there been
many other conflicts during my life that the
U S has been involved in some more over some,
some more covert.
We are in the same position a or better said.
We're in an insane position hoping that Iran,
which is not the most sober actor in history,
uh, we hope that Iran is the one that shows
restraint because of the actions of the president
of the United States. And as crazy as it is
under Donald Trump, Iran has shown more restraint
than we have. And people who have been watching
this show for awhile, you know, I am no apologist
for Iran. I am no apologists for Iranian regimes.
I am no, you know, I've said before, the people
of Iran are an increasingly young, progressive
population. The leaders in Iran are not that,
and I have been no shortage of extremely critical,
but in the Trump era, it's actually been Iran.
That's been the more rational and less erratic
actor in that relationship between the United
States and Iran. So get ready for the gaslighting.
You're going to hear things like, for example,
a Kaseem solo Mani was responsible for tons
of American deaths. You're going to hear Kaseem
Soleimani was planning to kill more Americans.
Sola was an enemy of the United States. Other
countries see Trump as the enemy in, in, in
many other countries. That doesn't mean we
go and start illegally killing people. It
doesn't mean that we go and start at least
attempting to create military conflicts for
what is obviously the, the possible political
gain that Donald Trump associates with a conflict
with Iran. This is a desperate attempt by
an impeached, at-risk president to try to
get himself reelected. It's a new year. It's
a new election cycle, and it is a new war.
That is ultimately what this comes down to.
The gaslighting. You know, I told you yesterday
I'm renewing my effort in 2020 to call out
the gaslighting because of HyperNormalisation,
because of the desensitization that we've
all experienced.
I would say even me, but it's sort of like
in particular me because I'm in this stuff
every day. We've got to prevent the gaslighting
and you are going to, you know, the issue
with Obama was congressional approval authorization,
so on and so forth that no longer matters
and now it's, Oh this was a bad guy. There's
lots of bad guys and it would not be justified
legally or morally to just go and assassinate
people in other countries. That's what Donald
Trump has done. You are going to be told very
different stories. Prepare yourself, arm yourself
with the facts in order to resist being propagandized
and by the way, information security responsibility
with sensitive information that also going
out the window with this assassination of
the Uranian codes leader. Let's talk about
that next.